good morning everyone i'd like to thank
lab roots for inviting me to speak
because of this virtual format i've been
asked to introduce myself
i am a pharmd grad from ucsf
and completed my residency with kaiser
in l.a
while at uci for 13 years as a
pharmacist specialist
in the department of peds division of
child development
i became an expert in compounding
running double-blind placebo-controlled
medication assessments
for the child development center and
using that skill for pre-clinical and
clinical trials
used for the development of several
drugs including concerta
with the alpha corp i ultimately
obtained two patents in neuropathic pain
and one in the buccal delivery of
cannabis
as a diplomat and fellow of the american
academy of
anti-aging medicine i have incorporated
cannabis into my functional medicine
practice
i need to disclose that my primary
employment today
is in the cannabis space both as a
clinician
researcher manufacturer and
educator
at the conclusion of this program
you should be able to list the most
common
medical con indications that cannabis is
used for
today discuss the importance of knowing
why the formulation in route of
administration
impacts the onset and duration of action
of phytocannabinoid therapy and discuss
the value of
cannabis as an alternative or adjunct
treatment
in chronic pain conditions with or
without
opiates so i'm going to
go over some basic uh cannabis
terminology
discuss general considerations when
recommending a cannabis product or
treatment
list the most common real world
medicinal uses of cannabis today and
share
peer-reviewed data to support the
indications discussed
and also present some case studies
regarding those indications
which picture on the left or right
depicts the cola
of hemp to even the trained eye
they are indistinguishable today on the
right
is hemp and on the left is santa cruz
tsunami
which is a four to one cbd to thc
uh uh cultivar
both plants are cannabis sativa l
which describes the species marijuana
and hemp
are regulatory terms used to describe
thc
content marijuana having greater than
0.3 milligrams per gram
of thc in the dry weight of the plant
and realize it is still
in the u.s a schedule 1 drug and by
definition
has no recognized medicinal value and is
highly addictive
hemp having 0.3 milligrams per gram
or less of thc in the dry weight of the
plant
in congress in october of
2018 define hemp
as an agricultural commodity
with all of its constituents legal in
states that have
an approved usda program and by default
federally legal
bacteria and fungi have strains plants
do not
strain is the layperson's term for
cultivar
describing phenotypically different
plants
common terms are sativa indica and
hybrid
hybrid is a mix of the two and
makes up greater than 95 percent of the
flower market today
varietal names include jack herrer
blueberry and cannatonic respectively
chemovar is determined by terpene
profile
cannabinoids potency and quantity
of standard biomolecules that make up
the plant at some point
we hope to utilize chemovar
as a method to ensure more reproducible
cannabis
experiences and effects
now most clinical studies of cannabis
today focus
on the contents of two phytocannabinoids
thc
and cbd regardless of the fact
that there have been identified 144
phytocannabinoids and now over 500
physiologically active substances in
cannabis
in this heat map the lcms concentration
of 36 cannabis cultivars up on the
x-axis are presented from work
out of david mary's lab in israel
in typical lab testing in the u.s
we only look at 9 to 13
cannabinoids as you can see
there's 10 different thc and
10 different cbd types alone
which speak to the difficulty a patient
or clinician has
in determining what mix of cannabinoids
are helping
or hindering treatment outcomes
now without getting into the weeds of
detail
there are three general terms for
extracts
full spectrum which
attempts to maintain the full profile of
the cannabis
plant that was processed broad spectrum
containing non-measurable thc
and attempt to maintain the remainder
of the full plant profile and isolates
which contain generally greater than 99
of a single cannabinoid the method of
extraction will determine
what components of the plant are able to
be removed
and that content varies significantly
based on
that method co2
uses either supercritical or subcritical
extraction
there's light hydrocarbon extraction
alcohol petroleum hydrocarbons
and many others some of them
artisanal including water
steam distillation oil extraction
like olive oil or butter or
cold press extraction
challenges facing a practitioner
with recommending a route of
administration
is that the products in that category
can be very different in formulation
in context
in the formulation you can have
excipients
and surfactants or diluents the content
of
actives the extraction method used
the forms of the apis
whether there is chemical or mechanical
modification of the cannabinoids the
bioavailability
is modified especially
with the route of administration
the onset and duration of action
because the pharmacokinetics of
cannabinoids
are non-linear and biphasic
as well as dose-dependent the genomics
of the individual
as well as the sex can have significant
impacts general principles on route of
administration and
ratios of the major apis
[Music]
we'll discuss but it is important not to
categorize
clinical outcomes based on the route of
administration
or the product form for an example
this is a patient that was seen in a san
diego
dispensary mid-30s
treatment resistant epilepsy on four
different medications and still having
about
eight seizures per day
the family was guided to
try a three to one ratio
of a sublingual oil based
solution 40 milligrams per mil
there wasn't any significant terpenes in
the product
and what was remarkable is within
24 hours this patient became
seizure free for the first time in his
life
and he stayed seizure free through
the remaining product
until they ran out went back to the
dispensary and asked for a three to one
sublingual solution and mct oil 40
milligrams per mil
and the seizures came back within 24
hours
they went back to the dispensary
discussed
uh you know their experience
and one of the staff was actually the
individual
that did the extraction and knew that
they used
two different cultivars so we went back
got more of the diamond og made the
extraction
and again the patient
became seizure-free so if we look at the
typical
certificate of analysis of the
cannabinoids
there were nine that were identified on
the c of a
and if you look at the label
on most products it will have cbd thc
maybe cdn and maybe thca
and if you look at those numbers they
look
almost identical
down on the far right some minor
cannabinoids
cbga and cdc
that was the most striking difference
in the sea of a and although
we can't claim causation
clearly this
is a perfect example of why you can't
look at one product and assume they're
all the same
these are some of the common routes of
administration used
they include inhalation whether
combustion or vaporization
there's even mdis out now
uh orally administered which
includes edible forms that i like to
consider as food candy and drinks
and then the typical pharmaceutical
routes of administration orally
sublingual in buckle depends on
placement in the mouth and it includes
all kinds of different formulations
topical includes transdermal as well as
every imaginable cream
roll-on lotion balm
they're all out there as well as
suppositories
now there are general principles we can
apply to routes of administration
and ratios of the major cannabinoids and
terpenes
that help with initial guidance on
choosing
a route or product the bioavailability
and duration of action
are substantially impacted by choice
of route and formulation
inhalation generally has an onset of
less than a minute
and a duration of one to three hours
edibles typically are
an onset of action of about 45 minutes
to
two hours but can extend to four hours
[Music]
as far as an onset and have
a duration of action which is
dose-dependent
of six hours to over 24 hours
what's in the stomach will have an
impact on
the onset of action
typically edibles have an unpredictable
onset
and duration for most people
sublingual meaning under the tongue
there's tinctures and fatty acid
solutions like olive oil coconut oil mct
and so forth typically have a 15 to 45
minute
onset of action but is variable based on
how long
the solution is held in the mouth
before swallowing as well as the solvent
ethanol being a much better
solvent than a fatty acids
which brings up you know as a pharmacist
miss brandy unfortunately our regulators
went to the high times pharmacopoeia
for guidance on dosage forms instead of
the usp formulations
make a difference in onset
and duration buccal absorption
between cheek or lip and gum
is again placement there's different
formulations trochees films odts
i like this round of events of
administration the best because it
generates the least
amount of saliva depending on placement
in the mouth under your upper lip is the
best spot
to allow something to dissolve
and create the least amount of saliva
onset of action can be as short as 3
minutes to 15 minutes
and is variable based on the formulation
and duration is typically four to eight
hours
now how could one adaptogenic or have
an effect on so many conditions
this is only a partial list of the
conditions patients use
cannabis for i've highlighted
and starred conditions that we see most
frequently
in our clinic and it includes chronic
pain
anxiety insomnia
and chemotherapy induced nausea
and vomiting and then the chronic
uh in you know pain conditions like
fibromyalgia
autoimmune disorders we see
considerable numbers of those
and we see
great responses in using cannabis
now to look at the myriad
of the endocannabinoid system receptors
involved in pain and this is
published from 2019 and
we've already found more receptors
now the national academies of science
engineering and medicine published a
report
back in 1996 on the medical evidence of
cannabis
following california voter approval
of prop 215 allowing the
medical use of cannabis first in
any of the states in january
of 2017 18 years
after their first report they did
an extensive review of the literature
focused exclusively on human literature
and did not consider basic research
conducted
using animal models
the committee reached nearly a hundred
conclusions uh from reviewing
uh more than ten thousand research
articles
and they broke it down into levels
of evidence the most
substantial being conclusive evidence of
clinical efficacy
this is in january of 2017 guys
and what is it list chronic pain
in adults conclusive evidence
2017 from a non-political
entity revered for their
uh for their skill set in
evaluating data
as well as chemotherapy induced nausea
and vomiting
and use of multiple sclerosis
with spasticity this was
2017 and cannabis
is still a schedule one drug in the u.s
a chronic pain comes with many disease
states
and chronic wounds are a source of
debilitating pain
the world health organization identified
chronic wounds as a major global public
health crisis
it affects up to six percent of the
population
females have twice the prevalence as
males
and the u.s spends up to 80 billion
dollars
annually it's associated with the opioid
crisis
and proliferation of antibiotic
superbugs
chronic wounds have poor healing rights
high reoccurrence rates rising
amputation rates high levels of
suffering
the costs we discussed and wound related
pain
continues to be poorly managed
pain in itself inhibits healing
so do opioids the mainstay
for treating wound related pain and
non-steroidals
you can see the list of side effects
here
from non-steroidals tricyclic
antidepressants
ssris tylenol
and so forth current treatment
guidelines
do not address breakthrough pain
epidermolysis bulosa is
a rare blistering skin disorder that is
challenging to manage because of skin
fragility
and repeated wound healing causing
itching
pain limited mobility and recurrent
infections in this case study of three
which used topical cbd oil
self-initiated and self-titrated
all case reports
all cases reported analgesia
reduced blistering improved wound
healing
and one case was able to be weaned off
of opioids
two pre-clinical work shows cannabis
extracts
promote wound closure and analgesia
nuc where non-uremic calcipholaxis leg
ulcers
carry a 45 to 80 percent
one-year mortality rate they're
difficult to treat
they're costly the response to treatment
is poor
and it's painful in the study of two
subjects
using two different topical formulations
of phytocannabinoids
it demonstrated a complete
closure of an nuc in
a mean of 76.3 days
and wound related pain was significantly
changed within 0.6 months and
they were able to dc analgesics
at 2.1 months
this is an example of one of the
subjects on the left
what the ulcers look like
and on the right full
resolution of the lesions
now jg in this case study it's a 52 year
old white male
a cannabis expert and activist he
tripped
walking in his nursery
early one morning and planted his face
on a concrete stair
he decided to treat himself no
md no stitches and it probably has to do
with his father being
a professor of podiatric medicine
he uses topical one percent
cbd thc topical spray
it was an ethanol extraction and
a one percent cbd spray which was
from an isolate the ingredients
other ingredients listed in his spray
are therapeutic by the way
he applied each solution four times a
day
cleaning with uh hydrogen peroxide twice
a day
so this is what it looked like following
his his dressing
of the wound about 36 hours
later day 7
and day 9.
let's look at pain in older adults
up to 50 of community dwelling
and 80 of nursing home residents have
pain
pain affects 80 percent of patients
greater than or equal to 85 years old
there's many common causes of pain
they include chronic disease states
post hepatic neurologists spinal
stenosis
nocturnal leg pain etc
pain leads to decreased functional
status
increased falls depression interrupted
sleep anxiety agitation
and a poor quality of life
[Music]
the adverse events associated
with typical pain treatment in the
elderly
include falls and fractures delirium
constipation
drug drug interactions dizziness
hypotension
a decreased quality of life
and uh the cdc actually reported
greater than 67 000 fatalities
related to opiate
overdose
in this israeli study
a prospective uh study of 2736
patients 65 years old or
greater using cannabis between
2015 and 2017
the most common indications pain and
cancer
after six months of inhaled cannabis use
93.7 percent reported improvement
in their condition a pain level dropped
from
a median of eight to a median of
four which is consistent with
other reported studies in the literature
the number of reported falls was
significantly reduced
most common adverse events dizziness and
dry mouth
and after six months of cannabis use
18.1 percent
decreased or stopped opiate usage
in this case study of rc a 76 year old
white female
a retired pharmacist she has a
significant past medical history
for fibromyalgia syndrome and
osteoarthritis
diagnosed in 1985
hypothyroid acylasia lyme and facet
degeneration
her chief complaints when we saw her at
the clinic
were insomnia a 9.5 out of 10
chronic pain status post
fall that injured her
back neck and shoulders
meds that she tried included just about
everything
current treatment low-dose
naloxone three milligrams qhs
herbs and nutraceuticals
physical therapy two times a week and
cannabis therapy we started her with the
cbd buccal troche
12 and a half milligrams uh three times
a day
it dropped her pain from a seven out of
ten to a four out of ten
we added a cbd capsule broad spectrum
twice a day and added a
acid and neutral form of thc in a six to
four ratio
10 milligram cap at hs
it dropped her 9.5 out of 10 insomnia to
a 3 out of 10.
we continue to adjust her cannabis
treatment
to the current therapy she's on today
which is 50 milligrams twice a day
uh she has a pain level at 3 out of 10
and her insomnia using a 30 milligram
dose
of the six to four acid to neutral form
of thc
has her down at zero to one out of ten
bj is a 73 year old white male
overweight retired judge and the father
of a close friend of mine
he has a significant past medical
history as being a
jock in high school wearing his body out
working on the loading docks during
college
and having a diagnosis of osteoarthritis
in 1991 in toes ankles and hips
he's six foot today 225 pounds
uh but he's been as high as 255 pounds
six and a half years ago he twisted his
left knee
with an eight to nine out of ten pain
and has no other medical
problems he has pain in his joints
and he could not with traditional
therapy
get below a six out of ten on the men's
tri
he has a 6 to 7 out of 10
rating of insomnia he tried
non-steroidals at the max dose until
renal function
started to decline he switched to
tylenol which
uh he continued to use until he got
abnormal liver function tests
he can't stand opiates and
so this was a challenge for me
and so i started him on
a therapeutic dose of molecularly
distilled fish oil
and remember that 2 000 milligrams
or more per day of epa
is a great cox 2 inhibitor
and we ultimately got him to try
cannabis once i got his pain down to a 3
out of ten
so we started with cbd 10 milligram
troche buckley three to four times a day
it brought it down another point
two out of ten but he didn't like the
taste or the route of administration so
he went
to an oral capsule starting with 25
milligrams in the morning
and going to 50 milligrams uh
in the morning he likes the taste
of a sublingual uh oil-based
cannabis solution 50 milligrams per ml
he uses between 100 and 150 milligrams
in divided doses depending on how much
activity
and pain he has during the day and
we finally got him on a cbd thc
18 to 2 ratio 20 milligram cap
of which uh now his pain is a zero to
one out of ten
and he claims he sleeps like a baby
again
now neuropathic pain
in this meta-analysis by mookie
reviewed 16 studies a total of
1750 participants
it used it looked at nubiximals which is
gw pharma's uh
uh sativex product uh
nablone uh cannabinol
two fda approved cannabinoids uh
placebo controlled studies
they even looked at a dihydrocodeine
opiate study and what
his meta-analysis concluded
was that cannabis based medicines may
increase the number of people achieving
50 or greater pain relief and the
cannabis based
medicine has probably increased the
number of people achieving pain relief
of 30 percent
or greater both compared to placebo
most of the literature regarding
fibromyalgia syndrome
is survey based
in this observational retrospective
study
of 56 looking at cannabis users and
non-users
with moderate to severe symptoms of
fibromyalgia
that were resistant to pharmacological
treatment
mean age of 50 and cohorts were matched
they utilized smoke or oral
administration of cannabinoids
the vas or visual analog scale was used
for perceived benefits
as well as three different surveys
in the results there were significant
improvements of the symptoms of
fibromyalgia
in patients using cannabis in the study
although there was
a variability in patterns it did
demonstrate
that there is a tie between the
endocannabinoid system and the stress
response system
in fibromyalgia and cannabinoid
treatment demonstrates a benefit
on the symptomatology
using a five-point likert scale
black beans strong gray
being mild and white
be no change there were significant
improvements in pain sleep stiffness
mood
and anxiety minimal
improvement and tiredness but that was
associated with
untreated adrenal fatigue that was
moderate improvement and headaches
looking at the perceived effects of
cannabis
the gray bar being pre-treatment and the
black bar
being two hours post-treatment again
shows improvement in pain stiffness
relaxation
somalians was actually a positive
measure
in this study as as well as uh
well-being
in this follow-up study to habib at
elle's 2018 publication
studying the characteristics of cannabis
use in fibromyalgia patients
in israel it looked at
[Music]
121 mean age of 45
73 female
identified the amount of cannabis used
per month
as well as the cultivars that were
most liked they showed
a mean improvement in sleep and pain
that was slightly more than
77 47
of the participants stopped any other
treatment
for fibromyalgia that's pretty
remarkable
october 2020 a randomized
double-blind placebo-controlled trial
was conducted to determine
the benefit of a thc
rich full spectrum oil on the symptoms
and quality of life in 17 fibromyalgia
patients this was an eight-week study
the fiq was used on
each visit which were which was
at every 10 days so they started uh
day one with an fifq and the dose
of the product that they were using
which was an
olive oil extraction of a cultivar
having 24.44 milligrams of thc
and .51 milligrams of
cbd they used one
drop and that was the treatment
every day and on date
each 10-day uh re-evaluation
they were able to increase that dose
by one drop if it was warranted
in the results the mean average dose was
3.6 drops
per day the fiq
baseline was similar with each cohert
the placebo versus cannabis treatment
was significant significantly
uh different
and the cannabis cohort
pre-imposed treatment was also
significantly improved so
their conclusions of this study that was
done in brazil
low-cost well-tolerated treatment
generated a better quality of life and
reduced
symptoms
in this case study a g a 28 year old
white female with daily migraines worse
around menstrual cycle
has had them for three years and
daily over the last seven months prior
doctors
prescribe pain medication and
preventatives that cause
bad side effects and minimal relief
she began taking a 12.5 milligram cbd
troche three times a day and adding
a acid and neutral form
of thc in a six to four ratio
10 milligram cap at bedtime to help with
sleep
by day two ag experienced reduced
migraines
uh her numeric analog score went from a
seven to eight out of ten down to
four out of ten by the end of the month
she was having days with no migraines
and now takes cbd is needed
when she has break a breakthrough
migraine
in this uh published study from our
clinic
an observational longitudinal study over
12 weeks looking at a primary diagnosis
of chronic non-cancer pain using the
buccal route of administration
of a troche the onset of analgesia
was between 5 and 40 minutes
the average reduction in a pain
intensity numeric rating scale
was 4.9 again similar to published
literature and of the 31 subjects that
were using opiates
26 or 84 reduced
or discontinued use with no reported
symptoms of withdrawal and 100
percent reported feeling
an improvement in a global rating scale
in this study blake at al
used a cannabis based uh medicine
sativex which is approximately a
one-to-one ratio cbd to thc
with placebo in a randomized
double-blind parallel group
study in 58 patients over five weeks of
treatment
the cannabis based medicine was
administered
by oral mucosal spray
in the evening and assessments were made
the following morning
efficacy outcomes assessed were pain
on movement pain at rest morning
stiffness
and sleep quality measured by a numeric
analog
scale as well as using the short form
mcgill pain questionnaire
and the das 28 for
a measure of disease activity
there were statistical least significant
improvements in pain on movement
pain at rest and sleep
there was no effect on morning stiffness
but the
baseline scores were low
adverse events were mild or moderate and
no patience
withdrew in
the retrospective review of low back
pain
patients on opiates at a colleagues of
mines clinic up in northern california
he did a chart review on october
of 2018 and
looked at his patient base with that
diagnosis
the median years on opioids were three
the morphine milligram equivalent
was 21 milligrams per day as an average
but the range was huge chronic users
made up 30 and intermediate users
31.
he identified the median cannabis
consumption per day as well as the route
of administration and forms
in his results he showed 50.8
percent which n of 30
stopped opioids the mean
length of time was 6.4 years
with a pretty substantial range there
there was 29 that nine reduced
their dose kept the dose the same
or the 17 actually increased
their opiate consumption
no variables collected predicted who
stopped opiates
but the higher cannabis usage had a
greater success
at stopping opiate consumption
in the international association
for cannabinoid medicines bulletin
january 31st of this year
release details of ming at al's
observational
study of patients remaining on cannabis
for six months through 12 months
patient reported outcomes in those
consuming
medicinal cannabis
the proportion of cannabis users who
reported
opioids decreased by half
from 40.8 at baseline to 23.9
at 12 months pain intensity
pain related interference scores were
reduced
quality of life and general health
symptom scores
were improved
there were 2 970
cancer patients treated in israel
between 2005 and 2017
of those patients 1144
were surveyed about pain prior to
cannabis
treatment 53 percent had a pain score of
8 out of 10.
at 6 months only 4.6 percent
had a pain score of 8 out of 10
and this is in a patient population
that is typically getting worse
of 1165 patients
surveyed about quality of life prior to
cannabis treatment
19 percent reported
a good quality of life and at six months
69.5 percent reported
a good quality of life 33.9 percent
on opioids prior to cannabis treatment
and at 6 months 36 percent discontinued
their
their opiate use
in this case study mev is a 60 year old
white female that works for the nevada
farm bureau
and is an avid horseback rider
as well as a sunbather she has a
significant past medical history of
hypertension
in 2010 and in 2016
uh she had uh the removal of a braf
positive cutaneous melanoma with clear
margins
and typically there's about a 98 percent
five year survival rate uh when
caught with clear margins
on eighth august of 2020 she got
pancreatitis
and in december of last year
she had a return of her breath positive
metastatic
cutaneous melanoma um
she has a significant family history of
a
younger brother dying from melanoma but
there were no details of that
and her chief complaints coming to me
was chemotherapy induced nausea and
vomiting a 9 out of 10.
she had no appetite at all she was
in excruciating pain and
had limited mobility she wasn't able to
walk
to her car without an
aid and she had um exhaustion
this is mev and that is her
melanoma
so she's been on the bertavi
mctobi protocol
hypertension treatment opiates for pain
and anti-medic therapy
when we saw her
and started cannabis therapy on her she
was
still on the chemotherapy protocol
on one antihypertensive and
on oxycodone 10 milligrams in the
morning
and in the evening we started her
on a one to five ratio of cbd to thc in
a sublingual oil
she was taking one half to one dropper
full
at bedtime only and within 12 hours the
family noticed
a significant difference she was able to
start eating again
and move better on the 16th
just three days later she was able to
dc her opiate and
was only on cannabis and chemo and was
able to walk
to her car
106 patients on continuous cannabis
therapy
that survived to interviews
six to eight weeks apart using
the common terminology criteria for
adverse
events showed a significant improvement
in their cancer or cancer treatment
related symptoms she
they had pain med reduction of 43
percent
severe pain drop of 26 percent
33 had a reduction in the use of
antidepressants
and or anxiolytics
this is a great free reference the url
is listed and i advise anyone
that uh is looking at
cancer treatment uh using cannabinoids
uh to take a look at this reference
now this was a poster presented in
september of 19 at the canmet
um program in
in pasadena and uh it was
created by kristen wolfslager
and elizabeth sherwood both of these
gals are nurses and part of the oncology
nurses society
and american cannabis nurses association
i know you can't see much of this but
when you get the slide you can
you know take a look at the detail that
is here
this is tremendous work done
mostly by kristen and she's one of the
leaders
in examining cannabis treatment for
breast cancer
this is a fabulous reference
now mp in this case study is 68 year old
white male
diagnosed two years prior with prostate
cancer grade 1 1g3
and had a high level of anxiety
and was looking for cbd to deal with the
anxiety
his previous treatment i refused
radiation
they tried uh freezing the cancer which
resulted in a treatment failure
and so he was really uh
done with any therapy he didn't do any
lifestyle changes at all and he
does have a significant uh family
history of cancer
he began taking a 12.5 milligram
cbd troche three times a day after
seven days with minimal
anxiety relief he increased it
up to 50 milligrams for 24 hours
what was remarkable is that his blood
work
continued to show a declining psa
and by the time that
it dropped to 0.9 the doctor did a
biopsy
blood work and ct scan which confirmed
complete remission with no detectable
prostate cancer
this is a url to take you to 420
television
to uh watch an interview from one of our
clinic's patients
that came to us with stage four
medistatic ovarian
cancer and we started her on a cannabis
program after her doctor
told her to go home and die
projectcbd.org a fabulous reference
i encourage everyone
whether you're a healthcare provider or
not to review it
i strongly recommend that you visit this
site
and learn the science as well as the
real life
issues involved with cannabis
therapeutics
these are some professional
organizations
as well as information
sites that you can take a look at
and i would like to thank you along with
a good colleague of mine we're standing
in west virginia in a hemp
field